un estrechón de manos como muestra la
unidad y solidaridad de europa con
ucrania el presidente ucraniano
volodymyr selenski recibió al presidente
francés de manuel marco al considere
alemán olaf scholz al primer ministro
italiano mario draghi y al presidente
rumano klaus johannis los líderes
afirmaron su voluntad de ver a ucrania
como candidato inmediato oficial de la
unión europea selenski insistió en la
importancia de este camino y se dijo
dispuesto a trabajar con el objetivo de
la membresía y estamos listos para
trabajar en nuestro estado para
convertirnos en un miembro pleno de la
unión europea los ucranianos ya se han
ganado el derecho para seguir este
camino y obtener ese estatus de
candidato está buscando previo al
encuentro los líderes visitaron los
suburbios de kiev escenario de las
primeras etapas del conflicto desde
irving mccann dijo ver señales de
crímenes de guerra y afirmó que francia
seguirá participando en su investigación
usted está aquí en el pin en un sitio
que ha sido destruido donde junto con
varias otras ciudades el ejército ruso
fue efectivamente detenido donde se
llevaron a cabo sacrest tenemos las
primeras señales de que éstos habían
sido crímenes de guerra
emanuel makoun también anunció el envío
de más armas a ucrania incluyendo otros
seis cañones propulsado césar un apoyo
militar previamente criticado pero
también minimizado por el kremlin
esperamos que no sólo se concentren en
discutir el apoyo a ucrania en términos
de suministro de armas es absolutamente
inútil sólo prolongará el sufrimiento de
las personas y dañará aún más al país
pero los dirigentes europeos aclamaron
el heroísmo de los ucranianos y los
invitaron a resistir para ganar la
guerra se comprometieron con el apoyo a
ucrania por el tiempo que sea necesario